don't do it
oh he's got a knife he's got a knife
what was the address they gave you
south meadowbrook
all right we'll have your suspect looks
like he's swinging around a cane
uh walking through the center of the
swinging
complex
cane around walking the center of the
complex and still checking for k-9 for
the southeastern hot call
and if you come in from uh meadow brook
on the far east side he's going to be on
the third row to the south
yeah so there's a unit coming in now
okay
[Music]
all right able keep going uh one more
row
and then make your first right he's
actually walking westbound towards the
apartments now make it right make a
right straight ahead he stand right in
front at the end
yeah before they were silent
over covers what up roger
all right everybody's got to cover it at
97 uh subjects walking towards the
officers
walking towards the officers
apartments now take your right take a
right straight ahead right now yeah
before they were sam i'm not
drop the cane
drop the cane
drop the cane
drop the cane
drop the cane
drop the cane ma'am
stand back stand back
that's okay he's about to get tased he
doesn't drop the cane
just drop it
drop the cane we got a call you're
hitting
that's the call we got so drop it and
tell us your side of the story or you're
going to be under arrest
drop the cane
there you go turn around
right now you're being detained
you understand that yes you are
hey
i'm not doing this
don't do it now you're under arrest
don't do it
oh he's got a knife he's got a knife
stay lethal stay lethal
kill me
go take
[Applause]
don't do it
oh he's got a knife he's got a knife
stay lethal stay lethal
shove me
okay taser deployed uh cover now still
he's up and trying to fight again okay
again cover now three south mountain
i lost him here on the screen
stop
stop
reaching stop reaching
he's reaching
stop logos
stop
[Music]
stop reaching
he's reaching
stop
metal broken brookhaven greatness
i was saying on
he's out on meadowbrook he's walking
westbound towards brookhaven
there's three officers 97 still
uncooperative
k9
are you available for uh
able cover now middle the intersection
brookhaven and south meadows
let go
your fucking hand
give me a hand
give me your fucking hand you're
arrested
you're fucking here
hey i'm gonna keep head control we're
gonna keep here you're gonna mount your
leg right here so i'm pulling him out
with it
okay keep pulling keep pulling a little
bit one more
all right now laying back flat laying
back flat
i got it my knee in here all right now
hey you get those two i'll start holding
the cuffs
all right
get the cuff on
let's just put a cuff on here
he's going back
up
you